please welcome nine-time guinness world
record holder in the art of whip
cracking
adam winrich
incredible i've always wanted to enter a
room doing that
that was fantastic wasn't that
incredible that was amazing you are the
world champion whip cracker first tell
us how did you get into this
uh i started when i was about nine years
old after seeing indiana jones
so that's probably how a lot of people
start i mean you could have seen an s
m film but you saw just how i got into
it uh
but you saw indiana jones and that made
you want to do it yeah it's funny
because we have a guy in our staff who's
also into whip cracking
uh jordan schlansky who also got into it
after watching indiana jones
and uh i don't know if he's here is he
here right now
oh yeah you don't debate no all right
well he was also into it for the same
reason uh
now uh tell me uh what are your world
records in uh my world records uh
there's nine of them
i think the cool ones are like the
longest whip ever cracked 216 feet and
then the most bullwhip cracks in a
minute 257.
260 a whip that was 216 feet long yeah
that's insane
what would be the purpose of having a
whip like that to set the guinness box
all right you're going to demonstrate uh
some of your talents for us i will step
safe where am i safe we're going to uh
back up over there by andy
yeah andy smart i'll be over here you
show us a quick demonstration right
there
the routine i like to call every which
way but loose
[Applause]
wow
that was that was crazy
i like how after all that you always end
in a flourish
is that important to always end that way
i think so okay
chloe now you're going to demonstrate uh
some special routines for us
i i'm guessing there's a lit candle here
either you're getting romantic with me
or that's part of a trick of some kind
is this you're going to what are you
going to do i'll try to use the crack of
the whip to put the candle out
fascinating okay again i will retreat to
the andy zone but you have at it
[Applause]
wow
that was crazy that was fantastic okay
what was that
oh well you have to have a pose and you
got to have a celebratory dance
when you do something do this this is
that's how i crack my
what is the next strip this the trick
this looks kind of complicated what is
this oh we have a
mug that mug's filled with water and
i'll just knock the bottle out without
spilling the water
you're gonna knock the bottle out the
cup will fall and the water will not
spill
yes behold
yes that was fantastic
now i'm told you need a different uh uh
you need a different whip for this next
trick what is this next whip
so this next whip i believe they're
going to bring it out here oh my god
look at this
this is a whip made of chain is that
correct chainmail
that's right that's fantastic what are
you going to why does this need to be
made of chainmail what are you going to
do
well what i'm going to try to do is uh
we got that can over there full of water
i'm going to shake it up a little bit
more
and try to cut it open with the whip
okay i think i believe that's
seltzer water you're going to cut that
can open using
this whip made of chains yes fascinating
i'll be over here
have at it good luck to everyone in the
first row
hold it there's still time
[Applause]
did you cut it open
don't slip now
[Music]
close enough close enough fantastic
uh i am a natural athlete uh
why would people laugh at that you're
not just born with this body
i can watch someone do something for
just a few minutes and one of my unique
abilities is then i can do it
beautifully
i think i've been watching you i think i
could maybe do this now
uh i'd like to try it if that's okay do
you think you could briefly show me a
few pointers
yeah sure i think we'll need a we got a
couple more whips now well first uh
safety first conan
now whips are dangerous it's a sonic
boom so we want some protective gear for
you protect your eyes
protect your hair what now is this
actual for actually for protection this
hat or just to look cool no it's
actually for protection
this is indiana jones if you were the
lead singer for you too
i love it this is a great look fantastic
all right hold on
all right what do you think what's the
first thing you're going to show me how
[Music]
to
okay what do i do first okay the most
basic way to crack a whip is the
cattleman's crack yeah
the whip in front just bring it up pause
at the top and bring it down so up
pause and bring it down up down br up
pause and this is the cattleman's crab
cattleman's crack i've seen the
plumber's crack
[Applause]
okay and i go just up
you're not you gotta back me up
that's no that's more just carnival
sadness
[Applause]
that's important what am i doing wrong
right here as i told you i'm an amazing
athlete so it's not my fault
slowly
you you got the whip to crack there you
just want to swing it up as fast as you
bring it down
and then when you pause at the back
it's just you want to get that timing
right there
okay conan now we're gonna make this a
little bit more challenging for you
whip the flower i was going to say
someone already whipped his genitals off
so
you can show that there you go
someone got guy doesn't want to live
uh just kill me all right now the first
important thing is now you got to uh
make sure you check the length of your
whip because you got to be the right
distance away
from the mannequins you get a little bit
closer all right and
you almost got the flower all right
there you go you got your distance
now you're going to want to yeah have
the whip in front right swing it up
right in line with the flap i'm going to
pretend
this naked asexual man
just threatened me with a daisy i'm just
trying to create a plot line here
and i need to defend myself okay let me
set
that whenever you're ready
hold it now remember to calm breathe
swing the weight yelling at me
i didn't yell when you did cool stuff
[Music]
you don't yell when i do something cool
now that was just intentionally showing
you how not to do it
whereas this is the way to do it
if you're not trying to get the daisy
this is my technique all right watch
this
we're gonna get this and then it's gonna
look so
freaking cool
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well adam as i told you all i have to do
is witness something for a few minutes
and i'm perfect at it adam thank you for
tolerating my idiocy
very talented very cool to have you on
the show